[Musique]
allez coupe tout
c'est quoi il y a peut-être des marches
d'escalier plus copains quelque part
on est des voleurs et on a été qui ne
fallait pas voler ce qu'il ne fallait
pas et libérer la plus grande force
maléfique que le monde est connu
les Magiciens Rouges ont créé une armée
de morts-vivants
ça a l'air sympa bien au contraire bah
oui je sais je faisais de l'ironie je
vois l'ironie comme une lame destinée à
couper le bras qui la tient toi tu dois
pas rigoler souvent
or et maintenant comment on fait on doit
réunir une équipe
venez près de l'orifice
l'orifice
[Applaudissements]
j'y vais en dernier
ça me va aussi
on pourrait mourir il y a plus grave que
mourir
[Musique]
que j'aimais le plus si on renonce
maintenant ça aurait été pour rien je
veux pas te voir mourir voilà pourquoi
j'aime autant sortir
vous avez perdu
le pont est protégé par un piège
ancestral il ne faut pas actionner le
mécanisme
j'ai peut-être actionné le mécanisme
désolé